How much zinc should I be taking so and how do you like to receive test results from
other practitioners.
So test results can just be sent to labs at countersclinic.com or info at countersclinic.com where they'll
go in your file.
If you want to talk about them then you just call them make an appointment.
How much zinc should I be taking as a general rule of 50 milligrams of zinc?
Every day is what you want.
Now, not all of you guys said this so you know because maybe some of the new people don't
know this.
When you've sent in like, oh, I'm taking this supplement.
Some of the reasons why I've said stop taking this supplement, it's not one of ours because
ours don't have this in there.
At least nothing that I would recommend is because it has copper in it.
So copper and zinc are like antagonists in your body.
You need both.
Don't get me wrong.
But you have this copper zinc balance.
Copper stimulates growth.
Zic doesn't have any growth but they're, they're a mineral complex in balance.
Most people with cancer have it accessible to copper to zinc.
So their copper zinc ratio is off.
Not horribly off but it's off and there's been a lot of assessment and some studies on
this.
Your copper zinc, zinc to copper ratio and that's why I don't think a cancer person patient
should be taking an exogenous copper.
You'll get copper at your food plenty enough for your body to stay alive and not have a
copper deficiency.
But it's, we can get too much copper, you know, people have copper canals, they have copper
pipes in their house, they have copper sources and, you know, people, this whole bad about
wearing copper jewelry for this or not or something like that excess copper that's all bad
for you copper at the top of that, it's all elemental copper which is even worse is throws
off our zinc balance and that can lead to at least a piece of the cancer puzzle.
So that's why I've taken everybody off of copper.
And just going off copper is usually brings the zinc balance back into place.
But should people take more zinc?
Well, anybody's taking any of our minerals you are taking more zinc and our minerals don't
have copper.
So, but how much copper, if, how much zinc should you take, it depends on what you're trying
to do.
Let's say if you have, if somebody called me and said, hey, I have warts, I just want to
get rid of my warts, I'd say, take 50 milligrams of zinc a day for a week and then
off a week and on a week and off a week and cut as good to cycle that like that for warts.
But, you know, typically 15 milligrams of zinc is fine, but 50 milligrams of zinc is taking
just more zinc.
You can't really overdo it, I can't overdo it on anything, I guess, but you're not going
to get rid of really overdoses zinc.